if you believe state media Russia has
been more successful in beating
coronavirus than almost any other
country in the world should Watson who
leads up a Coulomb controlling the
country supposedly has one of the lowest
coronavirus death rates relative to its
level of infection in the world but
leading doctors claim the official
figures are lies the handling of the
pandemic has drawn comparisons with the
cover-up following the Chernobyl nuclear
disaster it took the Kremlin leadership
more than two weeks to face up to the
problem members very well was the
collapse of the absolute number one aims
to avoid that scenario mr. Putin's
handling of the pandemic has led to the
lowest popularity rating of his
presidency will covert 19 undermine his
grip on power
[Music]
Russia has the third highest level of
corona virus infection in the world but
according to official figures the number
of people who have died of the virus is
remarkably low the fatality rate in
Russia has Russian officials themselves
trumpet is seven and a half times lower
than the rest of the world but we could
not trust the official figures these
startling images should just hang
overstretched it's health service has
become medics on the ground have long
suspected many more people are dying and
in defiance of the government a group of
doctors has compiled what they're
calling a memory list which names their
colleagues who have died on the
frontline treating patients with covert
19 what does he give me mm longer mr.
Whitaker Peter Stormare 30 and she said
I dunno Bertram talks because they touch
too strongly
absolutely Prabhavati
local journalists using the memory list
found the mortality rate among frontline
health care workers in Russia to be 16
times higher than in countries with a
similar infection rate but these deaths
don't show up in official numbers
because they're not being properly
recorded Russia is the biggest country
in the world it spans 11 time zones and
the memory list is now one of the main
indicators that the official figures do
not reflect the scale of the problem
it's even being used by some government
agencies in the absence of reliable
statistics this extraordinary not just
in terms of the window into the official
lines
it's extraordinary in terms of the sense
of a building responsibility in civil
society which works counter to the
authoritarian instincts of the family
it's not just doctors breaking rank to
report the truth
in May in Dagestan in Russia's North
Caucasus the Health Minister told local
media that the number of infections was
four times higher than reported although
at the time only 29 people had
officially died from coronavirus
hundreds more had mysteriously passed
away with pneumonia the minister's
suspected most of these deaths were
caused by covert 19 that produced
immediate reaction from who had to go
vision say okay you know that there is a
serious situation and occasionally this
picture of being in control and
defeating the virus starts breaking out
you see through the cracks that the
figures not real following an outcry in
local independent and foreign press
about the misleading statistics the city
of Moscow also had to admit that the
number of covert related deaths was two
and a half times higher than it had
previously reported in the early days of
the outbreak Putin didn't announce a
nationwide lockdown but declared paid
non-working days which many mistook for
time off next week the entire country
apart from those working Central
Services will effectively have a week of
holiday he left it to regional
authorities to impose restrictions you'd
expect an authoritarian ruler to be very
much the center of the crisis managing
it from it not wanting to be tainted by
it and not wanting to catch the plane
from the lockdown
he's trying to be the crown piece
because the biggest number you care
about is your rating not the rate of
infection
regional leaders were keen to prove they
were controlling the disease and duly
reported low infection rates to the
Kremlin but the numbers didn't add up to
assume that the Kremlin might not know
the real figures and this is the most
dangerous situation where the criminal
itself doesn't get the real data and
therefore its responses and its policy
decisions are going to be wrong because
they're based on the wrong date this
situation reminds some observers of
another dark period in Russian history
Chernobyl has claimed its first victims
from radiation perhaps the worst
accident in the short history of the
world's nuclear power industry we know
that was holding those meetings he
didn't know they didn't know the whole
station wasn't fine the real level of
radiation the local boss is trying to
cover their own bats there is a big
difference that was a man-made disaster
neither then nor now do I think that
people in charge of Russia have reliable
data and are therefore acting and making
the best policy for the interests of the
people based on the best reliable date
the Chernobyl nuclear disaster led to a
shift towards greater transparency in
Russia
thanks to Gorbachev's policy of glasnost
or openness hmm was a serving KGB
officer in 1986 he remembers very well
what happened after Chernobyl and what
those reforms have led to
the last thing he would want to do is to
repeat what he concedes too big of a
chores mistake to open up and liberalize
the system Putin is keen to put the
corona virus pandemic behind him while
parts of the country were still in
lockdown
he scheduled a massive military parade
for June 24th to mark the 75th
anniversary of the Soviet victory over
the Nazis covert 19 meant the original
celebration had to be drastically scaled
back in terms of legitimacy of Putin's
regime that celebration is absolutely
he's been preparing for it for a long
time which is why he was commenting
Putin hopes to rule Russia for the rest
of his life he's already used the
pandemic to increase restrictions on the
press and limit protesters and in July
he will hold a vote on a new
constitution which if passed would allow
him to remain in power until he dies
but his handling of the covert 19 crisis
means his popularity is at an all-time
low my fear is that Putin will try to
compensate the fallen popularity not by
opening up the country and liberalizing
it but by cracking down further right
certainly worrying signs of that already
happening in his bid to shore up his
power there's a risk Putin will become
more repressive and this will have
consequences that could stretch far
beyond the pandemic it will make the
peaceful transfer of power in Russia
more unlikely and leave the country's
future looking more unpredictable and
violent which is a concern not just to
its own citizens but the whole world i'm
arkady ostrovsky and i'm the Russia
editor at The Economist if you'd like to
read more about comet 19 its impact in
the world politics and on Russia in
particular
you can click on the link opposite
[Music]